[Music]
Dave Ramsey here and you're listening to
real estate the ramsy way where you
learn how to make the most of your
biggest financial asset your home today
we're talking about how to sell your
home without getting screwed and how to
do it with as little stress as possible
you'll hear from callers about some
common but tricky situations a lot of
homeowners bump into sooner or later
when selling sergy is with to start off
this hour in New York hi Sergey what's
up hey how are you Dave great man how
can I
help uh got a question for you about the
selling the house we've never done it
before uh we purchased the house now we
are looking to purchase another house
planning on and obviously question came
up to sell our house that we have right
now and um
there's uh when we go through realtor
there's
7% we have to pay for selling our house
uh and since you know I'm starting to
started to listen to the show and
working on uh eliminating our own depth
and we've done it uh we finished the
step two uh so now we I always
constantly me and my wife we always
think about you know everything
reasonably when we plan things and
everything so now we about this and
there's 7% and bugs me I don't have
peace in my heart to sell the house you
ever you ever had a
toothache have you ever had a
toothache yes I did before absolutely
did you use pliers or a
dentist dentist okay there's some things
you don't do yourself because you don't
know what you're doing you told me you
didn't know what you're
doing right yeah had friends this is
your most expensive
asset it's a hundreds of when you make a
mistake selling a piece of real estate
it ain't $10 dude I mean when you make a
mistake selling piece of real estate
it's tens of thousands of dollars and
you're in a whacka dude on world right
now for real estate it's cray cray out
there this ain't Amateur hour man you
definitely want a pro in your corner
it's going to save you more than 7% oh
and by the way let me help you with this
it's not 7% it's three and a half cuz
some Uber realtor will bring you an
offer if you'll agree to pay them for
their buyer portion of three and a half
and you're only going to end up saving
the sellers portion which is three and a
half and and now we're really down into
you're going to lose it a monkey can
sell a house right now but will they
sell it for the right price and without
a bunch of errors that cost you tens of
thousands of
dollars I wouldn't sell my own house
right now and I've had a real estate
license since I was 197 since
1978 you're going to make more and
you're going to have a lot less Hassle
and you know I I just I I don't even
work on my own cars anymore I don't know
I used to open the hood and get a 9/16
and adjust the I could watch this on
YouTube and fix it myself well I mean
there wasn't YouTube then but I mean I
could set the timing on the Monte Carlo
350 right I mean I I could do all that I
open the hood now and it looks like a
freaking spaceship under there I can't
even touch that stuff I don't fix every
time I try to fix my car now it cost me
more than it would have cost me to have
somebody fix my car cuz I break
something and that's what you're going
to do Sergey don't do it yeah i' I've
had a family member who did for sale by
owner and it was the worst nightmare and
I had tried to warn them to Ste stay
away from that but there are such costly
mistakes you make you're not reaching
the bigger Market because Realtors have
access to the MLS they take better
photos they understand strategy and
staging and what is going to cause
someone to pay more money and so in the
long run you're going to make more on
that purchase by going through a real
well and here's the thing okay let let's
pretend you get one of these houses that
people are going bananas okay where you
get like 60 offers or 40 offers or
something the seller it's almost
impossible emotionally for the seller to
manage that process and and glean
through that and get the best possible
deal and deal professionally with the
other 39 who don't get the house I mean
you've got to have some communication
lines open you have to have a process
basically you're conducting a freaking
auction in a lot of these situations and
you've got to know how to manage that
istically and and what the law says
about it you get yourself in a pinch man
I wouldn't do it I mean you can do what
you want to do but I think you're
getting a bargain at 7% uh if you get a
good real estate agent now I mean you
you got Uncle Charlie who got his
license three weeks ago and he wants you
to do it because he's family no
Charlie's dumb as you are don't do it
that you know he don't know what he's
doing either no you get a high octane
high quality real estate agent that
knows what they're doing it does a
couple hundred transactions a year when
they step in I mean you're you're never
going to feel the tooth when it comes
out that's true and everyone who's
worked with one of those amazing
Realtors goes that was worth every
single penny I paid them if you get a
good one you get a bad one it's like
anything else but I mean and it's the
same thing I mean I don't I don't I
don't do my own taxes I don't do I don't
write my own will uh I don't work on my
own car and I don't pull my own teeth
you know it's it's there's some things
you and you got all your teeth that
tells me done well it's it's working out
but the the DIY Thing um I mean it
there's some things you feel that way
about and you're wrong and this is one
of them it's the actual normal Market
data and I can't really talk about it in
this market but the normal Market data
is that a realtor sold house with a high
quality real estate agent will sell for
more than 7% more than the non-real
estate agent sold house that's normal in
this world who the crud knows I mean
because you don't even know what they're
going to sell for an asking price is now
suggesting starting point you know know
it doesn't mean anything anymore asking
price used to be suggested starting
point and I'm going to offer less you
offer less you're not getting the house
you forget it now in most of these
markets that's where we are well and
you're relying on a a sign in the yard
and then uploading to whatever site will
allow you to upload your iPhone photos
that were crappily taken and so when you
work with a realtor they know the
professional photographers they
understand how to Stage it they
understand how to Market it well they
understand every strategy around
contingencies and this is the kind of
Market we're in you're hiring a
marketing
professional for 7% I mean and if you
were doing something else that was a
$700,000 transaction and it was a
complicated transaction you wouldn't
think anything about paying the attorney
that did the transaction or whoever
whatever is you you it's part of the
process and a complicated thing and I
just highly recommended all the data
that's out there in a normal Market says
that you're worth that they're worth it
um in this market they're probably more
than worth it and those of you thinking
about buying a house same deal get you a
good buyer agent because I mean if you
go on ramsy solutions.com and click on
uh ELP for Real Estate endorse local
provider Ramsey trusted real estate
agents that we trust they're all high
octane we've vetted all of them we know
what they know what they're doing we you
know and if you're going to buy a house
in this world you've got to you know you
got to get some advice like you got to
have somebody go no those people are G
crazy walk away from that deal it's a
bad deal yeah you get too emotional when
it's just you yeah and you get bought in
on this one house and you start to make
stupid decisions Ephraim Is With Us in
Atlanta to start off this hour hey
Ephraim what's up hey Dave uh first off
you what you've done for me and my wife
and our family has just been incredible
we' listen to you we've read your books
and uh you've just been life saving so
thank you for that well thank you
actually you did it I just told you what
to do how can I
help well so I've been married for about
30 years to my incredible wife we are
living in the house that we raised our
girls in so we're at the point now where
we're empty nesters and of course like a
lot of people have a house that we just
it's it's too big for our needs right
now so with the housing market being
what it is I threw out the idea to my
wife to consider selling it and her
point was well if we sell High we got to
buy High well she's right about that
countered that with with going into
living in an apartment in an area that
we love it's a multi-use develop with
retail with restaurants we're there
probably three or four if not five days
um a week and we love it there so I
propose that we get an apartment there
for a year to enjoy living there and
wait for the housing market to come down
and then be ready when that time comes
to build a house or move into one or
whatever options we want to move forward
with we can but she's I think it's a lot
of sentimental that she doesn't want to
sell the house but the rental is about
4,000 a month which we could easily
afford and uh we would make probably
close to half million dollars on a house
net okay so she her her ultimatum was
well call Dave Ramsey and see what he
has to say on it
so I'm the tiebreaker yes you I don't
know if I can handle all this
responsibility it's a lot of pressure E
I got a lot of pressure here all right
so Let's uh let's change a couple of um
a couple of the variables in the
conversation okay sure number one I'll
give you a 99% chance that the housing
market is not going
down okay okay it has gone down two
times in the last 100 years the 1930s
and in 2008 it's only time it's gone
down okay and then it snapped right back
almost instant aneous in the 2008 less
than a year how even the areas like for
instance Las Vegas was the worst hit by
the bubble burst it was overbuilt it was
the fastest growing city in America and
it was and it basically the bubble
exploded there and we saw values come
down pretty substantially and um it was
uh 18 months and they were all back and
then it's gone nowhere but North since
then so I don't predict housing is going
to go down at all in this turn in this
round round uh my personal I do think
it's going to slow down its rate of
increase but that does defeat your
premise okay as far as renting until
then so is there a property in
the area you're talking about buying a
condo for instance that you guys could
just buy and move
into well we could okay hyp
hypothetically there there is actual
properties around the area you're
talking about where you're not a renter
yes it's obviously very very difficult
to find it and you have to be ready to
to almost make a cash offer because it's
it doesn't it's not on the market long
okay okay so uh if you could pull that
off it changes the discussion I'm not
going to tell you to go
rent you're going to lose that argument
so she wins okay uh okay because I think
you're going to end up going in the hole
with the rental amount and values are
going to increase albeit not at the rate
they're currently increasing so you're
you're going to lose money two different
ways by going to be a renter I'm not
opposed to you moving to that area and
moving into a less expensive property
and selling your property and buying
high and selling High which is her Point
uh but buying high and later buying
higher after having
rented no I'm not doing that one usually
and Dave you and Sharon just did
something similar so y'all have live
this um Ephraim normally I see couples
have this conversation and it's all
about the house and the
math and this is a much bigger
conversation which is this is we're
we're we're sliding into into phase
three right we've had our time together
we've raised kids and we're EMP nesters
and we built a tremendous home together
and a tremendous life together the next
phase is what do we want this next this
next season to look like and that it
will include discussions about home
where we live and do we want to go to
coffee shops and concerts we want to be
that couple we move out to the country
but that's a broader conversation that
as a part of that conversation will
involve grieving the the leaving the
house that you raised your kids in it's
got a lot of cool memories in and it
will what are your thoughts about
renting the house renting it
out yes why do you want rental
income I'm just ready for a change it's
a it's a 5,000 foot home that just we we
we live in the keeping room kitchen and
bedroom yeah
okay so I think that's the part y'all
need to start talking about before we
try to do a real estate deal I'm with
John so the two of you need to get
aligned on what the future picture is of
your life and it what the future picture
is okay it's a smaller more efficient
use of the real of the square footage
for you uh for her what is the future
picture and then what is the thing that
we can do that has all of the future
pictures in common yeah
okay um and uh and you know you're going
to give up some of you know like if you
have five things I want your bottom two
you might not get in terms of for forc
ranking and she has five things she
might not get her bottom too and that's
kind of what Sharon and I just went
through honestly um we did a little bit
of a similar discussion we had this huge
house and um was a good time to get out
of a huge house and so it's kind of
stage two empty nester for us um and um
and it was a good opportunity to cash in
and but we did immediately or
simultaneously buy another uh property
half the size that we moved into uh as a
temporary measure until someday we build
and uh but uh uh but we had a lot of
different goals with that that we both
aligned on the future now the deal is I
think if you if you'll start if the two
of you will sit down like John said and
start working on a future picture let's
paint the picture together what five
years from now looks like all right now
what are what has to be true for us to
get to that picture then you're going to
start making moves that are going to
cause you to sell this house move
downtown into a smaller condo as a
temporary move than later on build or
something like that you're going to
develop a game plan to end up at the
same place uh and this can be a romantic
fun it's an the word we kept using over
and over is this is a pain in the butt
and it's an adventure there you go we're
signing up for an adventure and uh you
know moving is a pain renovating a house
before moved in slightly was a pain with
no workers available youan moving is a
pain did I mention moving is a pain
that's the worst kind of like having a
root canal and you know but it's an
adventure because we and those are the
steps we took to get to where we wanted
to be 5 years from
today if you're thinking about selling
your home there's one thing you need
before you're 100% ready a top
performing high octane high protein real
estate agent who knows your market like
one of our ramsy trusted agents our
agents bring experience and confidence
to the table plus they've been vetted by
our team to make sure they put your
needs first use the link in the show
notes to see ramsy trusted agents near
you or go to ramseys solutions.com
agent Aaron is with us in Austin Texas
hi Aaron how are
you Hi D hi George how yall doing today
great man what's
up so I've got a question about selling
my my house um I'm just taking on a
promotion and so I'll be selling within
the next 30 days and I listen to you
religiously so I kind of know your
answer but I want to make sure
um instead of using a real estate agent
I I was thinking about selling it myself
and using my brother-in-law who's an
attorney um to do all the paperwork to
save in the realtor cost uh I did speak
to real estate agent that sold us the
house back in 2018 and based on the
comps right now she had told me about a
month ago that she felt very comfortable
listing the house at at least 2:30 or
I'm sorry 3:30 and so I was wanting to
go a little over that and um I'm looking
at maybe $20,000 in the fees so I just
he he would be doing it for free my my
brother-in-law so I just wanted to get
your thoughts on
that okay your brother-in-law is not
doing anything that the real estate
agent does when you sell a house you
typically use a title company or a
closing attorney to close the house and
you pay a closing fee and the closing
fee is not that much
money so you're not really saving
anything that the real estate agent real
estate agent doesn't close the house
anyway they just are the marketing agent
and they sell the house for you help you
with the negotiation help you walk
through the whole sale process and all
the details but when you finally get to
closing is the only time that you're
using an attorney you don't use an
attorney to draft a sales contract on a
residential
property sales contracts just written up
what about just written up by an agent
what about the profits though the
profits from the from the sell of the
house is don't they get like a 6% on the
profit of the sell of the house no they
get 6% usually of the uh sale price of
the house and there's lots of research
out there that shows that you will get
on average more than 6 % for the house
because you used a professional agent
that knows what they're doing and um and
so the typical house sold through a
typical good highquality realtor sells
for more than 6% more than the typical
fsbo for sale by owner like you're
talking about doing because you don't
know what the flip you're doing I mean
you already stumbled around your pricing
just in describing it to
us so Aaron let's walk through this if
you do it for sale bi owner let's say
you're able to sell for 300 because you
can't do any marketing and you're hoping
someone drives by whatever it is if a
you get a good real estate agent you can
clean it up stage it well professional
photos MLS listing the whole nine yards
you might sell for 335 which means you
made 35 more on that sales price than if
you did selling it on your own and let
me tell you here's what's interesting
let's pretend with this for a second
okay let's pretend that there was a
house next door to you that was the same
price with the same features for sale
with a real estate agent and your house
is for sale by
owner with the same price as the real
estate agent house next door okay which
is the way that you would pocket the
commission right you'd have to sell it
for the same amount
correct right and you put 6% in your
pocket if you didn't use a real estate
agent in that scenario and if that buyer
looks at these two houses that are
identical basically or they're on the
same street or they're next door to each
other they've got basically the same
features and the same Bryce and he comes
and knocks on your door instead of
knocking on the other door you got to
know what he's thinking hey I'll be able
to get this house cheaper cuz this guy
is not having to pay a
commission wouldn't
he yeah and guess what you can't save
the commission as the seller and the
buyer get a cheaper price save on the
commission as the buyer both it's the
same commiss Mission you both can't save
it and so it doesn't end up happening is
what happens and so it ends and your
time on the market is longer you're more
prone to make mistakes with the
valuation and what you put it on the
market for the mistakes and negotiation
are horrendous the things you leave out
of the sale contract that cost you a
deal because you don't know what you're
doing this this is your this is a your
largest asset all you're hiring when
you're hiring a good real estate agent
is a consultant that knows what they're
doing now I don't want you to hire a
bonehead real estate agent that got
their license that doesn't know what
they're doing and doesn't sell any
houses that's sweet if you got your
license you don't sell any houses but
you're not really a real estate agent
okay the people that sell you know 40 50
100 houses a year that's a consultant
that knows what they're doing they're
they're worth their money they're high
octane high protein and that's how you
get after it and so um you know just
just know I I would use a good real
estate agent I've had a real estate
license since I was n you know since I
was 18 years old
1978 and um It's Not Unusual well I
actually own a real estate company too
now but as as an internal as part of our
property management process so I use
them but they are real estate agents too
they know what they're doing to sell a
property for us we don't sell many
properties hardly at all but uh when I
listed my personal residence and I sold
it last year in 2020 I listed it with a
real estate agent again I full
disclosure I own the company but uh I
didn't keep the commission I paid the
agent the commission that works here
worked for me you know so uh and I know
what the flip I'm doing but I I also
know enough to know that I don't know
I'm not up on every little thing that's
going on out there right now because I'm
not doing deals every day I don't do 100
transactions a year personally yeah so I
want somebody that does if they're going
to help me with with an the marketing of
a high dollar asset get a real estate
agent and go to and don't necessarily go
back to your old agent your old agent
might be fine but go to Ramsey
solutions.com click on ELP get one of
our trusted people that has a high
octane high protein track record
interview three or four people if you
were going to hire somebody and pay them
20 grand which you are or 10 grand which
you are you know you you would interview
more than one you know that you're not
getting a haircut you're selling your
house that's right this is a big biggest
transaction of your life probably so
this is not Amateur hour I don't I don't
trust myself to do it and I've got a
pretty fancy camera and I feel like I've
been in the marketing world but this is
another ball game and I just hired an
electrician could I have youtubed it for
hours and probably got it wrong got in a
fight with my wife got electrocuted all
to save on the electrician fee
absolutely but I decided H I'm going to
let the pros do it and that's how I feel
about I don't I don't pull my own teeth
yeah I'd like to see you try Dave got a
dentist just tie it to the door knob
just grab that pie of pair of needle
those pliers and have at
it Mark is with us in Nashville hey Mark
how are
you good how are you Dave better than we
deserve man thank you what's
up hey um so uh we've been listening me
and my wife have been listening to your
show for the past six years and we're
able to pay off all our student loan
debt and um follow the baby steps and uh
we kind of got off the beat path a
little bit uh recently and we uh we
bought a piece of land uh we live in the
Nashville area and um we're kind of
facing this decision uh now uh we want
to be completely debt free and if we
sell our house and uh and uh rent we we
like to build a property on or build a
house on this piece of land in the next
three to four years um we would be we'd
be able to pay off their rest of the
land and be
completely um debt free and actually be
able to save a little bit more money per
month um while renting and um we were
just um kind of wondering if that was a
smart idea or or um I know there's just
so much going on with the the real
estate market in Nashville uh we're just
not sure what to do I have a really good
income um so we'll be able to save a lot
of money uh in the next few years good
what's your
income uh anywhere from 230 to 250
excellent very very good okay what's
your house
payment uh like $900 a month no you
don't sell your house you can't rent
cheaper than
that well we we have we have to pay
money on the land as well so yeah but
you got to pay money on the land if you
sell the house and
rent right but but we would be able to
pay off the balance of the land if we
sold their
house oh you take the equity out of the
house and do that okay so what do you
owe on the
land uh we owe about 260,000 what do you
owe on your
house about 200 okay what could you sell
the house
for uh about 500 okay I I would just sit
right there dude I'd sit right there and
I would plow through this land as at the
money at this land hand over fist get it
paid off and then start talking about
building a house on that
land okay I guess we just
um we just feel like you know in in the
next three to four years like if we sold
our house it it would it would take a
lot of risk out of everything if you
want to sell it sell it okay you don't
need me to do that okay but but but you
got to live somewhere and you have a
$900 house payment on a house that's
going up in value while you're pulling
off all these other
tricks and you're abandoning both of
those good things to go ahead and get
the land paid off and that's what I
wouldn't
do okay but you can do whatever you want
to it's obvious you're you know you make
a lot of money you're doing great none
of these things are in the stupid column
it's just a matter of which one's going
to be the fastest most expedient but I
mean you priced rent in Nashville
right yeah we we uh in the area that
we're looking um for the same size house
would be about 2500 bucks a month yeah
and I make about 20,000 a
month I know what you make a month is a
is a static piece of information in
either one of these
scenarios but the the two thing what
we're comparing against is 900 a month
that goes up in value or $2,500 a month
in the middle of the table on
fire yeah out of debt is your motivation
Mark for asking the question because you
guys just want to be pay everything off
and it just feels better and then you're
renting like is that what you're is that
what you guys are feeling both of you I
just I guess it just feels more simple
and it it just because because um I I
know that that like you you say that the
housing prices are supposed to go up but
there is a chance also that they could
go down and I just feel like if you're
going to sell you want to sell now I
think you're making a mistake because
you're you really do think house prices
going going to go down and I think
you're wrong especially in Nashville
Mark right I think you're wrong yeah I
think you've been hanging out with a
wrong people at the bar oh my gosh and
they're all talk they're all talking no
they're all talking trash let's Mar your
friends are all talking trash I want to
hear Mark what you have to say I really
do because I I hear the same thing so go
for our specific scenario um you know in
the next three four years that how much
our it's like how much our house is
really going to go up and is that worth
the risk of keeping it for that long
what's causing you mark to think that
your house price is going to go down
here in
Nashville why why do you think
that I don't know that it's going to go
down but I don't know that the amount
that it will go up is why why are you
coming to these
conclusions give me like data give me
reason because the the price of our
house is has more than doubled in the
past six years and I just I don't see
the that amount of increase the
percentage of increase I think it's I
mean it may increase but I don't know if
that increase over three to four years
is going to be worse the risk of us
keeping the house versus being out of
debt the
risk of the debt on the land yeah like
say the the debt on our our house and
the land like if say if something Happ
happen to my job or something in the
next three to four years it would be
pretty I don't know it you could sell
either one or both of these
properties yeah yeah I guess I just
worry about if the demand will still if
there's still going to be the demand at
the core of all of this back and forth
in your verbal is you really don't you
are really worried that house prices are
going to go down you really do believe
there's a high probability they're going
to go down and that's at the core of
your question and that's why I think
you're wrong okay now you can do what
you want to do there's no real downside
except a little bit of lost money on you
selling your house today uh but so sell
it today and go pay off your land and go
rent but then go back and look when you
finish this transaction 3 years from now
and see what that house that you sold
did and then we can determine if I was
right or not but um you know and Mark
let me say this though because the
marketing the market is softening it is
making people be like oh wow so yes
houses are going back to what they
actually are valued at and what
appraisal is coming in at not yes versus
in Nashville we all knew this like three
months ago I mean six nine months ago
someone here at the office they got 56
offers over a weekend like and it was
like 200 over asking I mean just you
hear the craziest stories you heard the
craziest you're not going to have that
anymore so think that's going to happen
but that doesn't mean that the value of
your home is going to tank because no
Supply is not going to catch up with
demands here in the near future and I
think that and I honestly do think that
there are still these areas around the
country we talked about this last
segment Assurance has
25,000 employees in downtown Nashville
Amazon has
25,000 employees in Downtown Health Care
industry in Nashville two companies you
can't beg a house in Nashville right now
because these huge corporations have
moved in here and made it their
headquarters okay and they're moving out
of New York they're moving out of
California and they're moving in here
and setting up shop because we're a tax
fre income tax you Houston Mark if you
were I mean another place maybe we could
have another discuss not a market that's
going to crash dude now again if you
want to do this the only thing you've
lost is whatever you didn't make on your
house and so it's not a huge like
there's nothing here in the stupid
column but what I what I want to teach
you and people listening is when you
make decisions based on feelings instead
of real data on negative feelings fear
it almost never leads to Good Financial
consequences and so at the core of your
concern at the core of your question is
a false assumption that real estate in
Nashville Tennessee is going to go
down in the next two years it's
not it's not if it does call me and I'll
buy your
house it's not okay ser
seriously all right folks I hope you're
getting the idea that selling your home
is always a big deal financially and
emotionally so you should only make a
move like that if it makes sense for
your individual situation bottom line as
long as selling your house won't hurt
you financially you're probably in a
good spot to sell now if selling
improves your financial situation that
could be a no-brainer but if selling
would make things worse either by
sinking you further into debt or making
your payments unaffordable then be
patient and stay put you'll be thankful
you did in the long run thanks for
listening to this episode and go ahead
and share this with someone you know
who's thinking about selling a home and
make sure to check out our next episode
about real estate
investing I'm excited about it and we
got a ton of requests for it you don't
want to miss it